[Music]
there's a big question mark hanging over
the world of business or public life
really and that is tie or no tie that's
become quite common recently to go
without one and even quite clever people
are doing it have a look at this this is
the CEO of Daimler he's cuddling up to
members of the German Green Party
talking electric cars and all that going
all Mark Zuckerberg what is he trying to
say with this performance look I'm
totally down with the average guy I'm
cool I'm totally rock and roll but he's
on the wrong side of 45 he's in blue
chip CEO so what he actually says is
this I'm faking this and I know that you
know it but I don't care sadly he's not
the only one so if you want to go for
this history teacher look you don't need
a tie but what if you're wearing a suit
what if you're meeting clients can you
go without a time yes you can but you
shouldn't two reasons one psychology not
wearing a tie means you're not really
sincere you'd rather be somewhere else
maybe on your sailing boat number two
aesthetics keep in mind suits are
designed to go with a tie if you don't
wear a tie with a suit it looks like
you're wearing a frame without a picture
so don't do it
at least in professional circumstances
unless of course you are Daniel Craig
but if you're faithful teachers are less
chiseled than his you can do with some
embellishment and also not wearing a tie
with a suit has become some sort of
trend and we don't follow trends do we
you